i'm sal khan founder of the
not-for-profit khan academy as you
probably know we have a big mission to
provide a free world-class education for
anyone anywhere and we know that the
most important people in that mission
are you the teacher and so that's why
from the beginning khan academy has
always worked closely with teachers to
be able to create tools for teachers so
that they can use it with their students
and allow the students learning to
happen as well as possible and so that's
why we're excited that you're a part of
this training because i've always said
if i had to pick between an amazing
teacher an amazing technology i would
pick the amazing teacher every time
the good thing is we don't have to make
that trade-off and so here at khan
academy we are trying to build tools for
you tools that will make your life
easier that will save you time and will
help you serve your students better so
khan academy is an online educational
set of resources
it is a combination of world-class
content
that spans from kindergarten all the way
to
12th grade and in some cases the first
and second year of college
and then we span across many subjects
there's two pieces that i think makes it
very unique one is
not just world-class content
but it's taught in a way that is very
easy to understand we also build a lot
of what we call social emotional
learning elements into the platform
because learning is hard it can be
intimidating you could feel
underconfident you could feel not very
smart learning something that's very new
to you so our product of content and
software the combination of both
we try to make it so it's easy to
understand
that it's fun that it's engaging that it
motivates you that it helps build your
self-confidence so that you can start to
be a self-motivated independent learner
to be a lifelong learner and what makes
us unique is those elements of not just
the content but the social emotional
learning part of the software
as well as we have a lot of built-in
intelligence to know exactly where you
are and all the steps that you need to
learn
so we have this thing called a knowledge
map inside our product that lets you say
gosh if i want to learn calculus someday
i need to know these foundational
elements first and then i can build on
top sort of like a house we have the
foundational elements and then you know
how to build the first story and then
you put the second story and we connect
all those dots for you our reach and our
scale today we are in over 190 countries
across the world
we are translated in over 30 languages
across the world by amazing advocates
volunteers that help us do this because
they believe so much in our mission and
it does really take a village to make
that happen
it is unfortunate there's a
misconception of us wanting to replace a
teacher absolutely not there is no way
that we can replace the teacher they are
such an important part of the student's
life
for us it's about providing tools and
functionality for the teacher to empower
them to give them agency to be
better than they can ever be to be more
efficient to be more effective so tools
and insights that we can do
to help the teacher so that they can be
the best that they can be for these
students
the people at khan academy are amazing
i am so blessed to run this company um
because the people
i have 200 plus people whose
sole
goal is to enable this mission to happen
um they just want to really transform
the educational industry to really help
those underserved children
and that's what they eat breathe and
sleep every day so we're excited that
you're part of this training hopefully
you will find everything that we are
able to provide for you to be of use and
we are looking forward to getting your
feedback about how together we can
better serve you and your students
thank you